[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis d'avoir trouvé pour
un nouveau numéro des matins du sénat
l'émission qui vous plonge au coeur des
débats de la haute assemblée ce matin
vous allez suivre le début de l'examen
au sénat du budget pour 2019
les sénateurs ont conclu hier la
discussion générale de ce projet de loi
de finances et les débats ont évidemment
porté sur la fiscalité écologique et la
hausse de la taxe sur les carburants
à l'origine du mouvement et gilet jaune
qui se rassembleront demain à paris et
cette hausse de taxe représente près de
4 milliards d'euros en plus dans les
caisses de l'état
l'an prochain la commission des finances
du sénat a montré que sur ces 4
milliards seulement 20 % devrait
financer la transition écologique
le reste devrait renflouer le budget de
l'état violents durant l'examen de ce
budget la droite sénatoriale va
supprimer cette hausse de taxes qu'elles
estiment injuste pour la population mais
le gouvernement a défendu hier les
mesures d'accompagnement de cette taxe
censée calmer la colère des gilet jaune
il est question par exemple de doubler
la prime à la conversion pour l'achat
d'un véhicule plus propre pour qu'elle
atteigne 4000 euros et le gouvernement
propose aussi de créer une prime pour
changer sa chaudière au fioul
le débat sur le budget 2010 9 c'est tout
de suite nous débutons aujourd'hui
l'examen du second projet de loi de
finance du quinquennat d' emmanuel
macron nous l'examinons dans des
conditions particulières la société
française connaît des tensions
exacerbées qui sont latentes depuis de
nombreuses années mais qui s'exprime
aujourd'hui concrètement jusque dans la
rue face à ces tensions
nous devons examiner la situation
budgétaire du pays et les solutions à
apporter
sans excès sans caricature avec
responsabilité et modération
il apporte de regarder les choses de
façon pragmatique
c'est la raison d'être du groupe les
indépendants en somme je vous propose de
regarder les choses telles qu'elles sont
et de débattre sur des faits et sur des
valeurs quelles sont les valeurs du
groupe les indépendants
la justice sociale la responsabilité
budgétaire et une efficacité économique
qui doit être mise au service de tous
j'ajouterai que nous sommes en faveur
d'un développement durable sur le long
terme
pragmatique et réaliste adapté au
quotidien de tous les français quels
sont les faits qui nous sont présentés
dans ce projet de loi de finances et les
chiffres sont un petit peu d'effet mon
cher collègue d'abord la fiscalité
énergétique augmente c'est un chiffre
c'est une réalité c'est factuel mais
elles augmentent moins que l'année
dernière
elle augmente d'ailleurs à cause d'une
trajectoire de hausse qui a été votée il
ya un an nous ne découvrons donc pas le
problème
même si certains font mine de le
découvrir toutefois je crois que le
gouvernement va trop loin oui il faut
changer de modèle de société où il faut
favoriser la transition énergétique
oui il faut tenir bon sur les ambitions
climatiques qui sont les nôtres qui sont
nécessaires et légitimes mais il faut le
faire avec pragmatisme et pédagogie il
faut s'assurer que personne n'est laissé
au bord du chemin de l'écologie un
chemin encore une fois que nous
soutenons et que nous jugeons nécessaire
nous aurons doit qu'à keur monsieur min
sur cette question de proposer des
alternatives crédibles à des hausses de
taxes indiscriminée et parfois
incohérentes
il faut sortir de la logique punitive
perçue par nos concitoyens où nos pme
notre responsabilité est de démontrer
que la transition écologique est une
chance pour chacune et pour chacun des
français
nous ne croyons pas qu'on puisse
rééduquer le peuple ça n'est pas l'adn
du groupe les indépendants ce que nous
croyons sais que nous pouvons l'incité
l'aider l'encourager mais pas le
rééduquer cette exigence doit dès à
présent être intégré au fonctionnement
même de l'état nous demanderons donc
ainsi au gouvernement d'introduire le
respect des objectifs du développement
durable de l'onu dans le processus
budgétaire pour éclairer l'orientation
des grandes politiques publiques
ce projet de loi c'est également le
véhicule de réformes majeures pour nos
entreprises
je pense bien sûr à la fiscalité des
brevets et l'innovation pour l'adapter
aux exigences de l' ocde
je pense également à la transposition de
la directive européenne à tad à la
réforme des modalités de calcul de
l'impôt sur les sociétés ou du pacte
dutreil
ces mesures sont parfois inévitables
souvent pertinentes mais elles doivent
respecter plusieurs conditions
d'abord la stabilité et la sécurité
juridique indispensable au développement
de nos entreprises
ensuite les législateurs que nous sommes
ne doivent pas avoir la main trop lourde
dans la transposition d'exigence
internationale nous devons nous devons
veiller à préserver la compétitivité de
nos entreprises et de nos centres de
recherche en europe et dans le monde
enfin il faut absolument respecter la
spécificité des pme et des entreprises
de taille intermédiaire qui sont
essentiels à notre tissu économique et
qui n'ont pas les mêmes capacités
d'adaptation que les plus grandes
nous seulement à cet égard monsieur le
ministre
l'esprit de ce budget dans la lignée du
précédent qui vise à donner de l'air à
nos entreprises et à placer l'emploi
en premier nous aurons à coeur de
contribuer à ce mouvement dans la
discussion qui aura lieu dans les
prochains jours j'en viens à présent aux
grands équilibres macroéconomiques et à
la question de la dépense publique
malheureusement en 2019
le montant des économies restent très
insuffisants la réduction des déficits
publics par exemple n'est pas
satisfaisante
certes le déficit effectifs et creusé
par le basculement du cicr en baisse de
charge
nous le comprenons mais la réduction du
déficit structurel qui mesure le
véritable effort des administrations
publiques est très faible et en
contradiction avec nos objectifs
européens
ce déficit alimente une dette publique
abyssale de l'ordre de près de 100% du
pib
et qui ne cesse de se creuser je cite le
haut conseil des finances publiques
la france n'aura pas encore amorcé à
l'horizon 2019
la réduction de son ratio de dette
publique au pib
à la différence de la quasi totalité des
pays européens
cette situation dont vous avez certes
largement hérité j'en conviens est
intenable
elle met en péril notre souveraineté
nationale nous n'allons pas non plus
assez loin dans la maîtrise de la
dépense publique et nous restons le
champion de l'union européenne en la
matière monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président je crois que vous l'avez dit
mot à mot ce matin et pourtant nos
marges de manoeuvre s'amenuisent qu'il
s'agisse du prix du pétrole qui
augmentent
qu'il s'agisse des taux d'intérêt qui
remonte qu'il s'agisse des tensions sur
le commerce international les
perspectives de la croissance mondiale
se ternissent ces facteurs risquent de
perturber ce projet de budget au moment
de son exécution et de vous mettre à un
moment ou à un autre
face à des choix difficiles la réponse à
cette difficulté est bien sûr plus
d'efforts plus d'efforts dès maintenant
plus d'efforts fera dépenses publiques
d'abord après avoir réalisé seulement la
moitié de la réduction prévue pour 2018
vous limitez aujourd'hui vos ambitions à
0.4 point de pipe d'économies soit à
peine 10 milliards d'euros
c'est trop peu plus d'efforts sur la
masse salariale de l'état ensuite vous
baisser trop faiblement les effectifs de
la fonction publique
nous sommes à 4500 e tp en moins en
moins en 2009
en 2019 pardon après une baisse 2006 ans
équivalent temps plein en 2018
ça fait donc un total de 6000 en deux
ans nous sommes loin très loin de la
promesse de campagne de supprimer 50
mille passes sur le quinquennat est très
très loin mais ce n'était pas un
engagement de votre part des 500000 d'un
autre candidat le passé nous enseigne
que ce type de promesses ne se tient pas
davantage en fin de quinquennat qu'au
début je dois néanmoins salué la
sincérité accrue de ce budget qui est
réel
c'est une promesse tenue monsieur le
ministre une sincérité formelle mais
également sur le fond des politiques
publiques j'en veux pour preuve la
mission dont je suis rapporteur spécial
pour notre commission des finances la
mission travail et emploi qui se
concentre davantage sur des dispositifs
qui fonctionne et sur la formation des
travailleurs sur les contrats aidés
c'est une question qui est revenue lors
des questions d'actualité le sénat en
tout cas sa commission des finances a
toujours été favorable à leur réduction
et sera également favorables cette année
comme l'année dernière à l'art aux
crédits de la mission travail un mot à
présent des collectivités territoriales
alors que se déroule en ce moment même
le congrès des maires des mères que nous
ressemble ici au sénat nous font part de
leur inquiétude et de leurs attentes
vous nous proposez une stabilité globale
des dotations ce qui est à mettre à
votre crédit après des années de
diminution drastique et indiscriminé
mais celle ci cache comme souvent de
grandes disparités selon les communes
nous vous proposerons des amendements
pour amortir la charge pour les communes
des plus défavorisés de plus la hausse
de la fiscalité sur le gnr inquiétante à
plus d'un titre pour le secteur du
bâtiment et des travaux publics aura
sans aucun doute un impact fort sur les
budgets locaux et pour les maires
bâtisseurs
enfin nous attendons des précisions sur
le remplacement de la taxe d'habitation
qui tarde à venir
je conclurai méchas collègues en
essayant de dissiper les caricatures que
j'évoquais en des buts de mon propos
nous ne croyons pas que vous opposiez
les français les uns aux autres à
travers ce budget ou vous choisissiez
une catégorie plutôt qu'une autre
nous n'y croyons pas plus que nous ne
donnions hier crédit aux soi-disant
budget pour les riches 2018
il faut savoir mesure garder mais il
faut également entendre monsieur le
ministre la détresse de certains
français de certaines entreprises aussi
qui est réel et il s'est exprimé le
premier ministre a clairement dit qu'il
avait entendu cette détresse nous sommes
confiant dans le fait qu'il prendra des
mesures fortes pour y répondre
notre groupe est prêt à vous y aider sur
la voie d'une transition énergétique
pragmatique sur la défense des pme et
des eti sur la promotion de l'innovation
à la française sur le respect line up de
l'autonomie des collectivités
territoriales et de la ruralité
nous avons des propositions à vous faire
pour améliorer ensemble ce budget le
temps presse et nous sommes
collectivement responsable c'est un
enjeu de cohésion nationale c'est un
enjeu de cohésion territoriale
c'est un enjeu enfin de compétitivité
internationale
faisons des débats autour de ce projet
de loi de finances un exercice collectif
positifs et pragmatiques au service de
la france et les français dans la suite
de la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur bruno
retailleau pour le groupe l'est
républicain pour neuf minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre ce le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général
mes chers collègues certes que le
contexte que nous connaissons cette
année et dans lequel nous allons devoir
examiner ce projet de loi de finances
est radicalement différent de celui que
nous avons connu l'an passé pour le même
examen de budget pour l'année qui est en
train de s'achever
à vrai dire le contrat s'est même
saisissant
on a d'un côté des français qui sont
profondément déçue déçue parfois jusqu'à
l'exaspération déçu au point de
manifester bruyamment
cette exaspération ou parfois ou plus
souvent même de façon très silencieuse
sondage après sondage
et puis de l'autre côté nous avons un
gouvernement qui ne change jamais sa
réponse invariablement si la même c'est
une réponse compassionnel j'ai entendu
le président de république la semaine
dernière j'ai entendu le premier
ministre
à chaque fois vous entendez la
souffrance des français vous la
comprenez à chaque fois vous estimez que
vous conduisez la meilleure des
politiques
il faut que nous éclaire ion et le débat
sur le pelley va nous en donner
l'occasion
ce paradoxe avec d'un côté un
gouvernement satisfait lui même
satisfaite politique et de l'autre côté
des français qui ne le sont pas eux
satisfaits alors sont-ils insatisfait
par tempérament
parce que les gaulois seraient
réfractaires parce que finalement s'ils
se plaignent et - la france irait mieux
elle se tiendrait mieux où sont-ils
insatisfaits parce que ils ont des
vraies raisons
je pense pour ma part qu'ils ont des
vraies raisons plusieurs raisons la
première c'est que il voit bien au fil
des mois que votre politique bien quand
bien même vous la présenter comme la
meilleure ne produit pas de résultats
le chômage bat si peu il se maintient à
un niveau extrêmement élevé l'inflation
repart l'inflation repart et la
croissance faiblit
vous allez me direz vous allez nous
objecter qu'il vous faut du temps
peut-être alors essayons d'élargir le
raisonnement essayons de relever
l'horizon de prendre de la hauteur et
d'aller voir chez nos voisins ce qui se
passe vraiment connaissez l'adage de
talleyrand quand je me regarde je me
désole mais quand je me compare je me
console le problème avec votre politique
celle inverse quand on se compare on a
plutôt tendance à se désole parce que la
france va pas mieux
la france en réalité décroche sur le
plan du chômage nous sommes passés mes
chers collègues sur 28 du 22e au 24e
rang
les performances que nous avons sont
plutôt des contre performances les
records que nous obtenons sont de
tristes records record sur la dépense
publique 28e rang sur 28 record de
l'oscd sur les prélèvements obligatoires
record aussi paru il ya un mois le 23
octobre de l' ocde sur 35 pays pour la
compétitivité fiscale nous sommes au
dernier rang au dernier rang ce qui
illustre bien le grand problème français
des déficits jumeaux à la fois déficit
budgétaire et un déficit du commerce
extérieur qui est en train de de se
creuser on ne peut pas s'en satisfaire
et ce budget est un budget de divergence
albéric de montgolfier de la dit très
bien de divergences européennes 31
milliards de plus que la france paiera
sur ses intérêts pour sa dette par
rapport à l'allemagne
alors quelle légitimité dans quelques
jours dans quelques semaines dans
quelques mois ce que nous aurons est-ce
que vous aurez à morigéner l'italie
quand nous mêmes nous serons en piteux
état pour nos comptes
quelle légitimité peut avoir le prison
de république à se présenter comme le
héros de l'europe à faire la leçon pour
tous les pays européens
quand lui même est incapable de mettre
un peu d'ordre dans ses comptes
ça pose un vrai problème si aujourd'hui
la france veut assumer un vrai
leadership au niveau européen pour les
vrais européens et pas seulement pour
les européens du discours les européens
des incantations évidemment donc
premières raisons qu'ont les français de
cette déception c'est parce qu'il n'y a
pas de résultats la deuxième raison
c'est parce que ml mâcon n'est pas au
rendez vous de ses promesses une de ses
grandes promesses souvenez vous avec le
monde nouveau le nouveau monde c'était
la transformation y at il une
transformation ce budget mes chers
collègues est il un budget de
transformation moi je me souviens très
bien de la déclaration de politique
générale de sa première déclaration de
politique générale du premier ministre
il avait eu ces mots l'addiction à la
dépense publique
la diction française à l'aide à la
dépense publique qu'en fait vous qu'en
fait vous vous en fait que la dépense
publique continue à galoper que pour la
première fois depuis dix ans le déficit
public en france est en train de
repartir à la hausse qui est assez
exceptionnel d'ailleurs malheureusement
en europe que monsieur françois hollande
vous connaissez bien vous l'avez soutenu
pendant ses deux premières années de
mandat a fait 37 milliards d'euros de
dépenses publiques et et belle macro au
même point en fait 51 milliards alors
est-ce que vous pouvez ce que vous osez
encore nous donner des leçons
franchement un déficit qui est désormais
celui de l'état alors que les
collectivités sont ouverts et alors que
la sécurité sociale est au vert seul
l'état ne fait pas les efforts qu il
pour autant devrait faire et il n'y a
aucune transformation de
mesure où ce budget ne porte aucune
réforme structurelle puisque l'effort
structurel français est précisément mes
chers collègues de deux fois moins par
rapport aux exigences européennes
la réalité elle est là aucune réforme de
structure
aucune réforme du périmètre de l'état et
vous attendez comme sous le quinquennat
précédent exactement la même chose vous
attendez demain vous remettez demain
pour les efforts sur la fonction
publique que vous devriez faire
déjà aujourd'hui je pense que c'est
quelque chose de dramatique en revanche
les vieilles recettes elles sont là les
recettes décalage d'un certain nombre de
mesures dans les recettes de rabotage
sur les familles sur les retraités ça
déjà été souligné et puis il ya une
troisième raison sur laquelle je
voudrais terminer
l'autre grande promesse emmanuel macron
au delà même de la grande transformation
c'était de réconcilier les français
je pense que votre politique ne
réconcilie pas les français mais que l
les opposent les uns aux autres sur le
plan politique je n'ai pas le temps de
le montrer sur le plan économique
oui cette politique et profondément
injuste injuste quand vous concentrer
les gains massifs de pouvoir d'achat sur
à peine 2 % des français la commission
des finances a fait de ce point de vue
là une excellente étude ajuste aussi
vis-à-vis des retraités qui subissent la
triple peine
une première peine qui leur a fait
attendre six mois de plus pour la
régularisation des retraites une autre
sur la cg une autre enfin sur la
désindexation des retraites et puis
injuste vis-à-vis des familles
françois hollande a commencé à casser la
politique familiale vous chausser ses
chaussures toujours pareil et enfin
injuste aussi pour tous ces français qui
ont besoin ces français des classes
intermédiaires ces français de la
ruralité de la rue urbanité qui ont
besoin de leur véhicule diesel
ils ont souvent deux pour pouvoir aller
au travail qui ont besoin d'acheter du
fioul domestique pour se chauffer parce
qu'ils n'ont pas du tout le choix ils
n'ont pas d'autre solution alors oui moi
je félicite la commission des finances
pour que nous ayons été cohérent par
rapport à ce que nous avions dit déjà
l'an dernier que nous ne supportions pas
et que nous demandions solennellement au
gouvernement d'annuler les hausses qui
sont prévus sur la tei cpe c'est
fondamental d'ailleurs j'observe que
aujourd'hui dans des grands quotidiens
du matin un certain nombre de grands
leaders de votre famille politique en
tout cas qu'ils vous soutiennent m est
aussi des doutes et vous demande
solennellement de renoncer à cette
trajectoire qui est funeste
vous savez puisque vous êtes un
budgétaire on parle toujours de la
réalité budgétaire mais c'est une
réponse comptable c'est une réponse
technique qu'est ce que cela signifie
politiquement la règle de l'annualité
budgétaire ça a un sens politique ça
veut dire que le consentement
1 la peau doit être annuel on peut pas
faire consentir les français sur une
trajectoire de cinq ans c'est ça la
règle de la nullité budgétaire elle a
une dimension proprement politique que
vous avez totalement oublié alors
monsieur le ministre vous nous répondre
et et ma la seule question que j'ai à
vous poser en achevant cette brève
intervention c'est que vous estimez que
la politique que vous menez est la
meilleure qui soit vous ne voulez pas en
changer vous estimez que votre cape est
bon alors pour et vous nous expliquer
pourquoi cette politique ne produit pas
de résultats
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole à monsieur rémi féraud pour le
groupe socialiste républicain pour cinq
minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
monsieur président de la commission des
finances chers collègues
face aux enjeux climatiques et de la
qualité de l'air la mise en place d'une
fiscalité énergétique a commencé il y a
déjà une vingtaine d'années pourtant
après la trajectoire décidé par ce
gouvernement
notre pays est actuellement plongé dans
une grave crise mais je ne crois pas que
cette crise soit due exclusivement ni
même principalement à la fiscalité
écologique
celle-ci certes mal calais est victime
de l'ensemble de la politique
gouvernementale de son injustice fiscale
manifestent depuis 18 mois comme des
promesses non tenues en matière de
pouvoir d'achat
certes la fiscaux de la fiscalité
écologique est un outil pour orienter
les comportements vers plus de sobriété
énergétique et ainsi pour réorienter
notre économie vers des pratiques plus
sobre et décarbonée mais quelle erreur
de l'avoir à ce point dissocier de son
impact social et c'est l'élu parisien
qui vous le demande monsieur le ministre
comment accepter l'idée qu'elle frappe
essentiellement ceux qui vivent en
milieu rural avec de longues distances à
parcourir parcourir et surtout qui ne
disposent pas de moyens de transport
alternatifs plus écologique sur lesquels
se reportaient sans véritables mesures
compensatoires à l'égard des ménages
modestes les plus dépendants aux
énergies fossiles
les mesures prises pénalisent de manière
particulièrement dures et injustes leur
pouvoir d'achat
le gouvernement le sait d'ailleurs très
bien puisqu'il répète depuis quelques
jours sans cesse s'il comprend les
français qui protestent mais il a décidé
jusqu'à présent de ne rien changer
c'est une attitude dangereuse car elle
renforce les frustrations nous le voyons
bien ces jours ci et par conséquent elle
risque de mettre en danger même la
notion de fiscalité écologique et c'est
d'autant plus aberrant que de nombreuses
pistes peuvent être ouvertes pour
répondre au mécontentement qui s'exprime
nous proposerons
ainsi un amendement visant à revoir la
trajectoire pour revenir à celles qui
avaient été définis lors de la loi
relative à la transition énergétique de
contrairement un gel complet ou un
moratoire durable cela ne remettrait pas
en cause la volonté d'aller vers un
bilan carbone neutre de notre pays en
2050 mais permettrait de prendre en
compte la hausse actuelle du prix du
pétrole et de laisser le temps dans les
années qui viennent de mieux répartir
les efforts et de repenser les mesures
d'accompagnement en faveur des ménages
particulièrement pénalisées on peut
aussi et claude raynal le disais tout à
l'heure envisagée la mise en place d'un
mécanisme permettant de préserver le
pouvoir d'achat des ménages par le moyen
d'une telle icpe flottante
il permettrait de rendre aux
consommateurs les surplus des recettes
de tva qui sont engrangés par l'état du
fait de la hausse des cours du pétrole
comme l'avait fait le gouvernement
jospin en 2001 nous proposerons là aussi
un amendement en ce sens
on nous répondra que l'effet serait
minime mais alors pourquoi le refuser
par principe
par ailleurs et c'est le point essentiel
nous considérons que les recettes des
taxes sur l'énergie devrait être
intégralement redirigés vers des actions
en faveur de la transition énergétique
et c'est certainement là que le bât
blesse le plus ce n'est malheureusement
pas ce qui est fait comme le montre
encore le reversement de 600 millions
d'euros de recettes de thé icpe vers le
budget général de l'état marque d'une
absence de volontarisme totale en
matière de transition énergétique
c'est un mauvais signal envoyé car tout
ce qui contribue à faire de la taxe
carbone une taxe de rendement budgétaire
lui fait perdre de sa légitimité
alors que de nombreuses pistes
d'amélioration des politiques publiques
existent comme l'aide à la rénovation
thermique à l'isolation des logements à
l'augmentation de la prime à la
conversion automobile aide à laquelle le
gouvernement se convertit lui même
lentement sans parler de la nécessité
dans cette période transitoire
d'apporter un soutien financier plus
important
aux plus modestes pour payer leurs
factures de chauffage ou de carburant
enfin je profite de cette intervention
pour renouveler notre proposition mais
en réalité très largement partagée d'une
conférence nationale sur le financement
de la fiscalité écologique afin de
sortir par le haut et avec tous les
partenaires concernés de la crise
actuelle et de l'impasse dans laquelle
s'est mis le gouvernement car la
fiscalité écologique n'est pas isolé au
contraire elle devrait être une
composante de la lutte contre les
inégalités
il n'est plus possible de concevoir
séparément politiques environnementales
et politiques sociales pour notre part
au groupe socialiste et républicain nous
pensons que cette transition énergétique
est une bataille collective qu'elle ne
peut se gagner que dans le cadre d'un
contrat social juste et donc acceptée
par les français
nous avons la conviction que c'est
possible si la volonté politique est là
bien sûr dans la suite de la discussion
la parole et à monsieur bernard delcros
pour le groupe de l'union centriste pour
dix minutes
[Applaudissements]
bien monsieur monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur prix dans
la commission des finances
il va nous rejoignent monsieur le
rapporteur général cher collègue
monsieur le ministre lors de la
présentation du projet de loi de
finances pour 2018
le gouvernement a fixé des objectifs à
court et moyen terme et je voudrais à
cet instant revenir sur plusieurs de vos
engagements et d examiner au regard de
la loi de finances pour 2010 9 sur
l'assainissement de nos finances
publiques
vous aviez fixé un cap sur la durée du
quinquennat - 5 points de dette publique
moins trois points de dépenses publiques
moins un point de prélèvement
obligatoire et le projet de loi de
finances pour 2010 9 s'inscrit bien dans
cet objectif
mais se pose me semble-t-il une question
malgré une amélioration réelle avec une
prévision de déficit public pour 2010 9
de 2,8 points de pib déficit qu'il faut
ça a été dit relativiser au regard du
reclassement de la sncf pour 0,1 point
et surtout de laisser cumulé pour la
seule année 2010 9,2 l'application du 6e
et de la première année de mise en
oeuvre de l'allègement des charges 09
points avec un taux de prélèvements
obligatoires que vous prévoyez en légère
baisse mais qu'il faut ramener à sa
juste valeur là aussi en le corrigeant
du double effet du cic de la baisse des
charges avec une dépense publique
certes réduite de 0 6 point de pib mais
dont on sait qu'en valeur absolue
elle augmente de 24 milliards d'euros
alors bien sûr sur la dépense publique y
aurait beaucoup à dire parce que
nombreux sont ceux qui considèrent qu'il
faut réduire davantage la dépense
publique mais c'est plus facile
d'affirmer qu'il faut réduire les
dépenses publiques que de préciser
quelles sont les dépenses qu'il convient
de réduire je pense que là aussi il faut
qu'on soit cohérent et responsable
avec une envie un niveau d'endettement
qui baissent légèrement de 0,1 point de
pib mais qui augmente en valeur absolue
de 67 milliards d'euros et alors que
s'assombrit le ciel conjoncturel
notamment avec le ralentissement de
croissance
pensez vous monsieur le ministre pouvoir
tenir le cap pouvoir atteindre des
objectifs fixés et gagner ce pari que
l'on sait difficile mais nécessaire du
redressement de nos comptes publics sur
votre engagement à gagner le pari de
l'emploi
après tant d'efforts sincère faits par
les gouvernements successifs sans
résultat probant temps de mesures qui
n'ont pas abouti à mettre en échec le
chômage de le chômage de masse vous avez
souhaité ouvrir une nouvelle voie en
faisant le pari de réussir a indiqué le
chômage par une meilleure compétitivité
de nos entreprises
l'allègement de leur fiscalité
l'allègement de la fiscalité du capital
la relance de l'investissement
cette année vous prolonger cette ligne
en concrétisant la bascule du cic en
allègements de charges en poursuivant la
baisse du taux de l'impôt société en
adaptant la fiscalité des petites et
moyennes entreprises aux défis de la
nouvelle économie et de la robotique
également par la modernisation de la
fiscalité agricole ou encore la mise en
oeuvre du volet fiscal de la loi pacte
qui devrait par exemple faciliter la
transmission des petites et moyennes
entreprises
comme je vous l'avais indiqué l'an passé
nous voulons bien vous suivre sur cette
voie en faveur de l'emploi là où tant
d'autres politiques ont échoué à
condition qu'elle s'accompagne de
mesures concrètes pour réduire les
inégalités afin de ne pas fragiliser les
plus démunis ou de ne pas à et de ne pas
laisser les territoires où certains
territoires au bord de la route
et si nous continuons à penser que la
réduction massive des contrats aidés ne
relève pas d'une bonne stratégie
je voulais le rappeler tant il
accompagnait utilement les plus démunis
et contribuer à l'offre de services
notamment dans le secteur associatif
alors bien sûr nous savons bien
les effets de vos choix en matière
d'emploi ne peuvent pas donner leur
pleine mesure immédiatement mais les
résultats devront néanmoins être au
rendez vous d'une baisse significatif et
durable du chômage
quelles sont vos prévisions en la
matière quand verra-t-on selon vous les
effets de vos choix politique et donc
une baisse du chômage en france
autre sujet d'actualité s'il en est
celui la transition énergétique
je pense que cette question est trop
importante pour sombrer dans le déni ou
la démagogie
nous sommes en train de détruire notre
planète c'est ça la réalité et les
conséquences nous les connaissons elles
sont alarmantes
peut-on continuer ainsi peut-on
expliquer à nos enfants que c'est
l'héritage qu'on veut leur laisser aucun
d'entre nous ne le pense et donc nous
devons l'assumer en responsabilité les
énergies fossiles ne peuvent pas être
l'avenir nous devons donc réduire notre
consommation d'énergie fossile d
accélérer le passage à d'autres sur nrj
accélérer aussi l'utilisation dans nos
pratiques industrielles agricoles
individuelles de produits respectueux de
l'environnement et de la santé publique
nous devons changer nos comportements
mais les mesures incitatives les taxes
incitatives pour être acceptée doivent
être comprises et pour être comprise et
doit être juste et pour cela il faut
premièrement qu'il existe une solution
alternative et deuxièmement quand cet
autre solution existe qu'elles soient
financièrement financièrement accessible
pour tous et c'est bien le problème
aujourd'hui comment faire accepter vous
êtes élu d'un départ d'un département
qui a sa part de ruralité comme le mien
comment faire accepter une hausse de
taxes incitatives aux habitants du
milieu rural lorsqu'ils n'ont pas
d'offre alternative pour se déplacer
comment faire accepter une hausse du
prix du fioul aux familles à revenus
modestes qui ne disposent pas des
ressources suffisantes pour financer le
changement de la chaudière
au delà du crédit d'impôt sert
significatif mais évidemment qu'il ne
finance que 30%
de l'opération monsieur le ministre je
le dis en responsabilité nous devons
garder l'objectif d'une accélération de
la transition énergétique
je pense qu'il faut garder le cap c'est
notre responsabilité de le dire et de
l'expliquer et rien ne serait plus
irresponsable que de prétendre le
contraire
mais pour réussir il faut accélérer la
mise sur marché solutions alternatives
il faut renforcer les mesures
d'accompagnement il faut revoir la
trajectoire de la hausse
enfin je voudrais évoquer rapidement
deux autres sujets sur la fiscalité
agricole je tiens à saluer le travail
qui a été mené en étroite collaboration
avec la profession et un groupe de
parlementaires auxquels vous avez bien
voulu m'associer l'agriculture joue un
rôle primordial dans l'économie de notre
pays et elle joue aussi ne l'oublions
jamais un rôle majeur d'aménagement du
territoire en faisant vivre la ruralité
le dispositif d' épargne de précaution
plus ouvert et plus souple le relèvement
du plafond pour faciliter la
transmission des baux ruraux la
possibilité de revenir sur son choix de
régime fiscal ou encore le maintien du
régime du micro mais à bien adapter aux
exploitations de petite taille est très
pratiqué en zone de montagne sont autant
d'avancé que je tiens à saluer sur les
collectivités locales vous êtes élu
local
vous allez occuper des fonctions de
responsabilité en tant qu'élu local
vous le savez les élus locaux ont besoin
d'y voir clair de tracer des
perspectives et quand des décisions sont
justes ils attendent quand les décisions
sont prises
ils attendent qu'elle soit juste après
une longue période de perturbations avec
la baisse importante de la dg ou la
réorganisation territoriale certaines de
ces mesures étaient nécessaires
d'autres sans doute que non en tous les
cas après cette période de perturbation
il y avait besoin de stabilité et de
lisibilité
vous avez apporté dès 2018 cette
stabilité temps dans l'es2 le montant
des dotations que dans l'organisation
territoriale
c'était nécessaire pour 2019
le maintien de la dgf à son niveau de
la hausse de la péréquation ou encore la
réforme de la dotation
d'intercommunalité d'intercommunalité
qui revient sur le dispositif injuste
des catégories de pci vont dans le bon
sens de même que la péréquation à
destination des départements qui ont le
plus de difficultés à faire face aux
dépenses des allocations individuelles
de solidarité
toutefois je vous le dis la réduction
des crédits affectés au contrat de
ruralité à la prime à l'aménagement du
territoire au fisac que vous connaissez
bien
ce sont des petites sommes et qui on
enlève un effet de levier important ne
sont pas acceptables pour les
territoires ruraux les plus fragiles la
commission des finances proposera de les
relever
je veux aussi insister sur la
modification des périmètres consécutifs
alors un autre et le changement de
catégorie décor et des intercommunalités
qui ont considérablement impacté la
répartition des dotations entre les
collectivités notamment au niveau de la
dgs et au niveau du fonds de péréquation
intercommunale et communales le pic une
remise à plat est aujourd'hui nécessaire
et j'ai compris que vous étiez prêts à
engager ce chantier enfin nous suivrons
avec la plus grande attention le projet
de loi sur la réforme de la fiscalité
locale qui devraient être examinés au
printemps prochain
la commission des finances a d'ores et
déjà fait des propositions concrètes sur
ce sujet je vous remercie
merci chers collègues quelques mots
d'abord pour rappeler que ce projet de
loi de finances comporte un certain
nombre de réformes structurelles d'abord
en matière de compétitivité puisque
c'est une diminution de 19 milliards
d'euros que nous mettons en place pour
permettre et accompagner la création
d'emplois avec le renforcement des
mesures d'allègement qui avait déjà été
programmé comme avec la mise en place
d'un allégement en remplacement du
crédit d'impôt compétitivité pour
l'emploi j'ai entendu monsieur le
sénateur rénale votre intervention
disant que finalement ce n'était pas
utile et que le groupe auquel vous
appartenez considérer inopportun de
transformer s'est hissé en allègements
de charges ne voyez pas de malice à ce
que je vous rappelle que c'est pourtant
un engagement de françois hollande
devant le monde des entreprises
à l'occasion des voeux qu'il avait
prononcé en 2016 deux ans après que nous
ayons mis collectivement en place ce
crédit d'impôt nous pensons que c'est au
contraire il mesure utile et une mesure
qui nous permettra à la fois de
simplifier l le travail des entreprises
et qui en année 2010 9 permettra aussi
aux entreprises de bénéficier d'une
trésorerie conséquente dont nous
espérons qu'elle favorise
l'investissement
par ailleurs nous poursuivons la volonté
de revaloriser le travail avec une
exonération des cotisations qui entre en
vigueur pleinement et avec la volonté
d'exonérer les heures supplémentaires de
cotisation sociale à compter de
l'automne prochain
ainsi que de supprimer les le forfait
social à la fois sur l'intéressement et
la participation
selon la taille des entreprises ces
mesures sont financées par des économies
qui sont substantielles certains de
certains de ces mesures d'économie ont
été évoquées par les uns ou par les
autres
nous pouvons citer par exemple le gel du
point d'indicé en matière fonction
publique qui représente une économie
d'un milliard 800 millions d'euros
la rivale russe la revalorisation
maîtrise et de différentes prestations
sociales ou encore la limitation à 2 5%
de l'ondam même si avec un taux de 2 5%
c'est un des drames les plus élevés de
ces dix dernières années au total à
l'échelle de ce plf
ce sont plus de 6 milliards d'euros de
coupes de pouvoir d'achat que nous
vendons aux ménages avec il est vrai 3
milliards d'euros de fiscalité
supplémentaire dont une partie est liée
à la fiscalité écologique j'y reviendrai
dans un loft ans mais surtout 9
milliards d'euros d'allègements dont
quatre autour de la question des
cotisations salariales ou 3,8 au tour
des hordes de la taxe d'habitation
pardonnez moi j'ai entendu monsieur le
président otayo que vous vous inquiétiez
de l'absence de résultat cette politique
vous me permettrez de m'inscrire en faux
jo tout cas ça lui sera rapporté
j'imagine puisqu'au contraire nous
considérons que cette politique porte
ses fruits avec un déficit public
inférieur à 3% dès 2017 pour la première
fois depuis 11 ans qui a été reconduite
et qui sera reconduit en 2018 et que
nous tiendrons aussi en 2019
même si et je remercie celles et ceux
qui l'ont noté nous avons un ruisseau du
déficit en 2010 9 du fait de la
transformation du cic en d'allégements
de charges le déficit de 2010 9,8 en
réalité de 1 9%
auxquels il faut ajouter de manière
extrêmement conjoncturelle les 0.9 point
de pib qui correspondent à cette double
années en matière de séismes
la dépense publique est très nettement
ralenti avec une stabilisation totales
en volume pour 2018 puisque nous serons
sur un ton volume à 0 % et plus
largement nous pouvons noter que la
confiance et retrouver notamment auprès
des acteurs économiques puisque le
dernier baromètre de l'attractivité un
agneau indique que 77 % des
investisseurs étrangers notamment
déclarent avoir confiance dans l'avenir
de l'industrie en france poursuit
concerne le chômage
je veux souligner devant vous que celui
ci a connu une baisse de près d'un point
depuis 2016 pour les plus jeunes cette
baisse est encore plus importante
puisqu'elle est de 2,6 points en un nom
et il faut le souligner est ce que cela
signifie que ces résultats sont
suffisants non nous ne nous arrêtons pas
à ses premiers résultats et nous nous
employons contraire approfondir et
accélérer notre action avec des
objectifs ambitieux vous connaissez en
matière de comptes publics à l'horizon
cinq points de moins de dette publique
trois points de moins de dépenses
publiques
deux points de déficit et 1 point
prélèvements obligatoires de manière à
tenir les objectifs arrêtés en loi de
programmation dans cette trajectoire
l'étape ont tout sache toute sa charge
et toute sa part contrairement à ce que
certains d'entre vous ont pu affirmer
les dépenses de l'hymne de l'état pour
la norme pilotable baisseront de 0 5% en
volume en 2019 soit une augmentation en
valeur de 0 8% et il faut le comparer à
une hausse de 2 3% des dépenses locales
investissement et fonctionnement compris
ou encore de 2,5 pour cent des dépenses
d'assurance maladie en matière fiscalité
écologique puisque à la fois les
dispositions de ce projet de loi de
finances comme l'actualité invite les
uns et les autres à souligner cet aspect
je ne peux que rappeler pour commencer
ce qui a déjà été fait et lui redire le
répéter devant vous la hausse de la
taille c'est peut être un vecteur
carbone dont je rappelle qu'elle a été
votée à
l'occasion du mandat précédent et ce qui
semble parfois oubliées ne tient pas son
caractère écologique de son affectation
et d'ailleurs ce n'est pas une assemblée
parlementaire que j'apprendrai que le
principe d'universalité budgétaires
empêche ou en tout cas interdit la
généralisation d affectation de
ressources sinon nous n'aurions plus une
loi de finances mais un simple
empilement de compte d'affectation
spéciale le principe de la fiscalité
comportementale que nous mettons en
oeuvre
tiens au fait de décourager la
consommation de produits nocifs pour
notre santé ou pour notre environnement
et non pas de financer des dépenses
nouvelles et ça va explique largement la
philosophie qui est la nôtre en matière
de fiscalité écologique
le premier ministre a annoncé récemment
de nouvelles mesures d'accompagnement
qui amplifiaient née d un effort déjà
considérable du plf 2010 9
je veux souligner que le budget du
ministère la transition écologique et
solidaire est en hausse de 3,1 pour cent
soit plus d'un milliard d'euros sur un
total de 34 2 milliards d'euros ce qui
au passage en terme d'ordre de grandeur
est un rapport à rapprocher du fruit de
la fiscalité écologique et
environnementale cela nous permet de
dégager des crédits en faveur des bonus
électrique et de la prime à la
convention qui sont augmenté de 57% par
rapport à la loi de finances initiale
pour 2018 et le gouvernement a tenu
compte du succès massif de cette prime à
la conversion qui bénéficient en grande
majorité
un déménagement d'imposables puisque 70
% des bénéficiaires de la prime sont des
ménages non imposables
de même chaque énergie sera portée de
150 euros en moyenne à 200 euros par an
ce qui représente un engagement
budgétaire de 740 millions d'euros
contre 560 millions en 2018 je voudrais
m'arrêter un instant sur un point
particulier en matière fiscale et que
fiscalité écologique
pour couper court aux mauvais procès sur
les annulations de crédits de fin
d'année notamment sur les ajustements
c'est en paix les faire sur le compte
d'affectation spéciale transition
énergétique
nous avons tout simplement pris les
dernières estimations de charges de
service public de l'énergie réalisés par
la commission de régulation de
régulation l'énergie c'est un calcul qui
a été fait à partir du prix l'énergie
notamment en juillet 2018 et la suite
d'un conseil d'administration
18 juillet 2018 les dépenses du compte
d'affectation spéciale transition
énergétique sont des dépenses
obligatoires liées aux contrats de
production d'énergie renouvelable et non
les dépenses discrétionnaires
ces dépenses seront ceux relevant se
révèlant pardon moins élevé que prévu
ni l'état ne va pas sûr qu'on pense et
les opérateurs en 2018 car ce serait une
dépense à la fois inutile et illégitime
un mot si vous me permettez sur
l'outre-mer pour dire que les crédits de
la mission outre-mer sont en hausse
d'une manière inconnu jusqu alors c'est
une hausse sans précédent avec plus de
20 % puisque la mission totalisent 2
milliards 400 millions d'euros dans le
plf 2010 neuf suite aux assises d outre
mer la ministre en effet et vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur lurel des décisions
courageuses au bénéfice direct des
territoires ultramarins la suppression
la tva une paire dont toutes les
évaluations montré qu'il s'agissait d'un
dispositif obsolètes et inefficaces
comme la révision de l'abattement le
lierre pour les seuls ménages les plus
favorisés
soit les 4 % de ménages les plus
rémunérés nous aurons à l'occasion de la
discussion d'un certain nombre
d'articles occasions et en présence de
la ministre d outre-mer de revenir sur
chacune de ces dispositions
je tiens à souligner que ces économies
ont été entièrement réalisés au budget
de l'outre-mer avec des as direct à
l'investissement et au développement
économique pour plus de 170 millions
d'euros
un mot enfin sur la question des
collectivités territoriales pour
remercier les différents intervenants
qui ont pris soin de souligner que d'une
manière globale les concours de l'état
aux collectivités territoriales étaient
stabilisés il s'élevait à 47,8 milliards
d'euros en 2017 48,1 milliards d'euros
en 2018 et ils sont prévues à hauteur de
48 2 milliards d'euros dans le plf 2010
9 la question était posée du lien en
tout cas de l'explication à trouver a
donné entre le maintien de la dgf à un
niveau absolument stabiliser et les
évolutions connues par de nombreuses
communes
la répartition de la dgf tient à deux
aspects le premier aspect est évidemment
un aspect démographique et
l'augmentation ou la diminution de
population peut entraîner une variation
de la dotation forfaitaire
le deuxième aspect tient à des
mécanismes propres et un terme à la dgf
le premier relève de l'écrêtement de la
dotation forfaitaire pour financer des
emplois internes notamment en matière
d'augmentation la péréquation verticale
le second tient au fait que la dgf est
aussi alloués aux communes et notamment
pour ses pas repéré quoi la dsi la dsr
et souvent la dsr cible au potentiel
financier agrégé des communes le
potentiel financier agrégé des communes
tient compte d'indicateurs sociaux
économiques propres à la commune mais
aussi propre à l'intercommunalité
d'appartenance la modification
importante de la carte intercommunale au
1er janvier 2017 a d'une manière
automatique entraîner une modification
forte de nombreux potentiels financiers
agrégé des communes qui ont vu
l'intercom leurs intercommunalités
d'appartenance évolué
cela explique alors qu'en 2010 cette
dernière année de baisse de dotation la
dgf avaient été versés sur la base du
potentiel financier pour sa part perd et
coin de 2016 avant le changement de
l'intercommunalité
alors quand en 2018 la dgf a été versée
pour la partie des coûts et sur la base
du potentiel financier agrégé du dernier
exercice connu soit 2017
après la modification de la carte
intercommunale à critères constant
l'année 2019 s'annonce sous de meilleurs
de meilleurs auspices pour une raison
très simple c'est que la carte
intercommunale a extrêmement peu bougé
au 1er janvier 2018 et ainsi le
potentiel financier de référence 2018
est logiquement très peu différente
celui de 2010 est à l'exception des
évolutions liées à l'amélioration la
dégradation d'une situation économique
et sociale de telle ou telle
collectivité et je crois que cette
nature à être rassurant vous avez aussi
évoqué madame bavarde la question des
variables d'ajustement
c'est devenu à mon sens le symptôme du
fait que le système de financement des
collectivités territoriales est arrivé à
bout de souffle puisque bien souvent
dans nos débats au sénat comme à
l'assemblée
nous sommes plus concentrés sur la
question des variables d'ajustement et
leur répartition que sur la question des
dotations forfaitaires et du plus
important des dotations versées en 2010
est dans la loi de finances initiale les
variables d'ajustement s'élever à 923
millions d'euros en 2018 elle s'élevait
à 323 millions d'euros dont ont été
retranchés par une décision de gestion
environ 120 millions d'euros au t2 la
desserte et paie des intercommunalités
que gérald un mona et moi même avons
décidé de ne pas me
rés après l'adoption du projet de loi de
finances pour 2018 nous sommes
aujourd'hui à 144 millions d'euros je
cite les spots ces trois chiffres
plus de 900 323 144 pour démontrer
l'effort que le gouvernement fait afin
de minorer les variables d'ajustement à
répartir et ainsi nous éviter à la fois
ses débats mais aussi le sentiment
d'injustice que connaissent les
collectivités dont la dotation baisse du
simple fait des variables d'ajustement
le président de la république a indiqué
hier devant les maires réunis à l'elysée
qu'il souhaitait qu'il était favorable à
un débat sur les modalités de
répartition tout en soulignant combien
il était difficile d'aboutir à une
solution qui satisferait tout le monde
quand on sait que l'enveloppé normée et
que les marges de manoeuvre budgétaires
sont quand même relativement contrainte
il a aussi en écho à ce que vous avez
évoqué est ce que d'autres ont évoqué je
pense notamment aux sénateurs delcros
évoqué la question de la fiscalité
locale pour indiquer qu'un projet de loi
de finances rectificative serait
présenté au printemps 2010 9
le premier ministre il ya un instant
indiqué devant le congrès des maires que
ce serait à la mi avril devant le
conseil des ministres
nous avons un objectif qui était de
tenir l'engagement pris par le président
de la république l'année dernière à la
même période d'assurer aux collectivités
une compensation intégrale une ressource
qui soient pérennes qui soit juste et
qui soit durable
nous aurons à travailler dans les
prochaines semaines sur de nouvelles
modalités de répartition du fruit des
impôts locaux
nous aurons à travailler a précisé ce
qui doit être pause qui doit être
compensée parce que six supprimés et ce
qui ne sera pas compensée parce que non
supprimée et nous avons d'ores et déjà
indiquer la volonté du gouvernement de
ne pas supprimer la taxe d'habitation
peut-être faudra-t-il ont changé les
termes mais de ne pas supprimer la
fiscalité liés aux résidences
secondaires ni supprimer les outils à la
main des élus locaux en matière
notamment de lutte contre la vacance des
logements ou d'une exploitation
commerciale particulière comme on peut
en trouver en zone touristique et à
paris notamment
cela nous permettra aussi d'ouvrir un
débat sur la manière dans les
collectivités et l'état pourront
continuer à percevoir certain nombre de
taxes ou d'impôts je pense à la
contribution pour le financement de
l'audiovisuel public à la taxe ou la
redevance d'enlèvement des ordures
ménagères ou encore à la taxe spécifique
est inculte hâtive mise en place dans le
cadre de la gestion des milieux
aquatiques et de la prévention des
inondations
autant de sujets auxquels nous
veillerons cela nous permettra à
l'occasion de ce plfr spécifique
d'arrêter le modèle de financement et le
modèle de la fisk et de la répartition
des impôts locaux restons après 2021 et
la période d'extinction de la taxe
d'habitation dans l'attenté de la fin de
sa période d'extinction nous
continuerons à compenser les communes
grâce à la technique du dégrèvement qui
est la plus protectrice puisque les
maires qui perçoivent des taxes
d'habitation en 12e ont pu constater que
ces douzièmes ne diminuaient pas mais
qu'au contraire les douzièmes avait
intégré le dynamisme des bases et un
certain nombre de revalorisation et
voilà pour cette discussion générale sur
le budget 2010 9
vous avez vu le président du groupe
l'est républicain bruno retailleau
très remonté contre ce budget car selon
lui les finances publiques vont se
dégrader le déficit du budget se creuse
il va passer de 2 6% à 2 8 % de la
richesse nationale et la droite critique
des mesures qui pourraient diminuer le
pouvoir d'achat par exemple le gel des
aides sociales à les pensions de
retraite les aides au logement et les
allocations familiales
et puis évidemment cette hausse de la
taxe sur les carburants qui provoque le
mouvement des gilet jaune
sur ce point les sénateurs socialistes
proposent une taxe flottante
c'est-à-dire qu'ils baissent si le cours
du pétrole augmentent et inversement
pour ne pas faire flamber les prix à la
pompe
et c'est une proposition qui est relié
par le président du modem françois
bayrou
mais à quel mais à laquelle le
gouvernement a déjà dit non et après
cette discussion générale
les sénateurs sont entrés dans le vif du
sujet avec l'examen des articles et ils
ont commencé par valider la contribution
de la france au budget de l'union
européenne
elle s'élève à 21,5 milliards d'euros
soit plus de 5 % de nos dépenses
je vous laisse écouter ce débat nous
allons maintenant examiner l'article 37
relatifs à les voler
l'évaluation du prélèvements opérés sur
les recettes de l'état au titre de la
participation de la france au budget de
l'union européenne dans le débat la
parole est à monsieur patrice joly
rapporteur spécial de la commission des
finances pour cinq minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous
examinons aujourd'hui le montant de la
contribution de la france au budget
européen pour 2019 ce débat est très
encadrée puisqu'il s'inscrit dans le
cadre financier pluriannuel de l'union
européenne prévue pour les années de
1014 2020 toutefois ce n'en est pas
moins d'exercice important répondant à
une exigence de transparence et de
démocratie en 2019 le montant du
prélèvement sur recettes est estimée à
21,5 milliards d'euros contre 19,9
milliards d'euros inscrits en loi de
finances pour 2018
si on y ajoute 1,7 milliard d'euros de
droits de douane la contribution totale
de la france s'élève à 23,2 milliards
d'euros pour la deuxième année
consécutive le montant du prélèvement
européen est en hausse et il atteint
même un niveau inégalé depuis 2014
les hausses les causes de cette hausse
sont bien connus elles proviennent
essentiellement d'un effet de rattrapage
de la consommation des crédits européens
en particulier ceux dédiés à la
politique de cohésion et au
développement rural
mécha colère avec dur et oui son nous de
cette augmentation qui devrait
bénéficier à l'eau territoire à ce
propos je vous rappelle qu'en 2017
safran c'était le troisième contributeur
net en volume au budget européen mais
surtout le premier bénéficiaire nette en
volume ainsi en 2017
13 5 milliards d'euros du budget
européen ont été dépensés en france
principalement au titre de la politique
agricole commune
l'examen du montant du prélèvement sur
recettes mais cependant en évidence deux
inquiétudes
premièrement celle de la volonté de la
volatilité pardon du prélèvement sur
recettes et de son impact sur les
finances publiques
l'évaluation inscrite dans le projet de
loi de finances est en réalité bien
fragile elle dépend des prévisions de
l'union européenne des éventuels budget
rectificatif et des corrections
apportées sur les exercices antérieurs
l'année 2010 est nous a montré à quel
point cette évaluation était difficile à
réaliser puisque l'écart entre la
prévision et la réalisation s'est élevé
à plus de
virgule 3 milliards d'euros il semble
que nos partenaires européens
rencontrent les mêmes difficultés que
nous pour éveiller évaluer le montant de
leurs contributions
mon second sujet de préoccupation et
celui des difficultés rencontrées ces
dernières années pour le versement des
primes de la pac aux agriculteurs et
celui du retard du décaissement des
crédits européens pour le développement
rural
c'est particulièrement criant pour
certains programmes comme le programme
leader sur 500 millions d'euros prévus
pour la période 2014 2020
seulement 10% d'euros ont été
effectivement payés à ce jour alors que
les dépenses européennes en france sans
conséquences sont conséquentes ce sont
les territoires les plus fragiles qui
peinent à en bénéficier
certes à contribuer à l'augmentation du
reste à l'équité qui devrait d'ailleurs
atteindre le niveau record de 300
milliards d'euros en 2020 soit près de
deux fois le budget annuel de l'union
européenne on mesure l'impact négatif de
ces retards sur les dynamiques
économiques des territoires qui doivent
être accompagnées dans leur
développement
monsieur le ministre cette situation est
incompréhensible pour nos concitoyens il
est urgent d'y remédier jean vient
désormais au budget de l'union
européenne pour 2019 lundi dernier des
négociations entre le conseil et le
parlement européen ont échoué de façon
inattendue en raison d'un point de
blocage sur l'utilisation des crédits du
programme de recherche horizon 20 20 il
s'agit de 400 millions d'euros sur 160
milliards ce qui en dit long sur
l'engagement européen de certains la
commission européenne doit désormais
proposer un nouveau projet de budget au
delà du budget européen pour 2019 c'est
évidemment le prochain cadre financier
pluriannuel qui définira l'évolution des
contributions de la france dans le
contexte actuel de désordre mondial avec
une guerre commerciale qui s'aiguisent
la multiplication des conflits
l'importance des flux migratoires et
l'accompagnement des nécessaire
transition notamment écologique
l'europe doit être à la hauteur des
enjeux de plus aujourd'hui les peuples
européens sont désabusés désorientés
parfois désespéré selon témoigne en ce
moment le mouvement des gilet jaune le
sentiment d'abandon qui trouve les
peuples européens se traduit sur le plan
politique par la montée des populismes
le bric site où la conduite par certains
états de stratégies individuelles ou de
repli sur soi les risques sont donc
devant nous le cadre pluriannuel doit
traduire les orientations politiques
fortes
or mises à part les discours du
président de la république adressé à nos
partenaires européens
les traductions politiques sont
inexistantes au plan le sol national
cela ne facilite pas la compréhension le
partage est l'acceptation par les
peuples notamment le nôtre des
politiques européennes à plusieurs
reprises j'ai appelé à faire preuve de
plus d'ambition pour définir le plafond
des dépenses de l'union européenne
j'espère que les élections européennes
permettront d'avoir un vrai débat sur
l'avenir de l'europe
en attendant je me réjouis que le
parlement européen ait renouvelé son
souhait d'un cadre financier pluriannuel
s'élevant à 1,3 pour cent du revenu brut
de l'union européenne monsieur le
ministre
pouvez vous nous confirmer que la france
ne se posera pas à une légère
augmentation de la contribution à
l'avenir
enfin notre commission des finances est
interrogé sur la question des
investissements notamment portuaires qui
devront être réalisées en france à la
suite du bric site
ces investissements seront utiles
financée uniquement par la france avez
vous des éléments de précision à nous
apporter
en conclusion et au delà de ces
observations et sur la base d'un
approche d'une approche strictement
budgétaires et comptables
je recommande au nom de la commission
des finances l'adoption sont
modification de l'article 37 de la loi
de finances pour 2010 n'est guère dans
la suite des discussions la parole est à
monsieur jean françois rapin
remplacement de monsieur jean bizet
président de la commission des affaires
européennes pour 3 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur spécial permettez moi
d'ailleurs de saluer votre travail
monsieur patrice joly pour en tant que
rapporteur spécial de la commission des
finances
vous venez de nous présenter avec clarté
les enjeux de la contribution de la
france au budget de l'union
comme l'an passé cette contribution
augmente mais paradoxalement les causes
de cette hausse sont vertueuses c'est en
effet que l'utilisation des crédits
européens s'accélère enfin et que les
projets portés par la politique de
cohésion et de développement rural se
développe
cinq ans après le début de l'actuelle
programmation depuis quelques mois les
négociations ont commencé sur le
prochain cadre financier pluriannuel
2021 et 2027 dont la commission a
dévoilé le projet en mai dernier
ces négociations sont difficiles je
crois qu'il est illusoire d'espérer une
adoption définitive avant les élections
de 2010 9 ce projet de cadre financier
pluriannuel est le fruit d'obligations
et de contraintes nouvelles qui doivent
conduire à des réformes longtemps
retardé les obligations et les
contraintes sont connus c'est d'abord la
chute des recettes que va entraîner le
départ du royaume uni de l'union
européenne ce sont ensuite les nouvelles
priorités politiques qui auraient émergé
ces dernières années et auxquelles il
n'a pas été possible d'apporter de
réponse satisfaisante pendant l'actuelle
programmation budgétaire sécurité
frontières migration jeunesse recherche
et innovation
le projet pour 2021 et 2027 leur accorde
cette fois ci une large place malgré des
recettes moindres et des priorités
nouvelles il n'est pas pour autant
concevable que des pots dit que des
politiques dites traditionnelles à
savoir la pac et la politique de
cohésion soient sacrifiés ou
marginalisés c'est la troisième
obligation politique que devra respecter
la prochaine programmation
la france a déjà et doit encore se
battre sur la ligne rouge que représente
pour elle et pour beaucoup d'états
partenaires la réduction des crédits de
la pac
face à ces contraintes des opportunités
de réformes sont enfin à portée de main
en premier lieu les nouvelles ressources
propres qui devront faire du budget de
l'union
un enjeu de valeur ajoutée européenne
plus politique que celui du seul juste
retour en second lieu celui de la
simplification il est essentiel car au
delà du seul enjeu administratif il y va
de la proximité de l'union européenne et
de ses citoyens
les réformes préconisées sur la
politique de cohésion ou sur la suite du
plan juan john coeur que sera le
programme d'investissement invest ue
vont dans le bon sens troisième
opportunité la suppression des rabais et
ristournes divers accumulés au fil des
ans le projet de la commission pour 2021
et 2027 ans prévoit la suppression sur
cinq ans il faut à notre sens le faire
en une seule fois le plus tôt étant le
mieux reste deux enjeux sur lesquels je
vais conclure dans le cadre de la
négociation le parlement européen vient
de réaffirmer son objectif d'un budget
qui représenterait 1,3 pour cent du pib
au lieu de 1,1 pour cent actuellement à
sept unités du parlement européen répond
cependant une division cacophonique de
la part des états membres
second enjeu si comme on peut le
craindre le prochain cadre financier
pluriannuel n'est pas adopté avant les
élections de 2010 9
au delà du risque politique que l'on
peut redouter surviendra le risque
budgétaire de voir démarrer les
programmes avec les mêmes retards que se
rencontrer en début de l'actuelle
programmation je vous remercie
merci chers collègues à la suite de la
discussion générale la parole est à
monsieur pierre aux oulias pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologistes pour sa minute
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues en préambule j'aimerais
rappeler combien nous regrettons la
place moindre concédé dans cette
enceinte au débat sur la politique
européenne
lesquels se dérouleront de plus après le
conseil européen des 14 et 15 décembre
réduire à une question de deux minutes
l'intervention en séance révèle
l'intérêt porté à la question européenne
dans cet hémicycle
merci à -2 à -2 185 jours des élections
du 26 mai 2010 neuf je prends donc la
liberté de mettre à profit ces cinq
minutes pour vous faire part de mon
grand trouble à donner un avis technique
et comptable sur le prélèvement opéré
sur les recettes de l'état au titre de
la participation de la france au budget
de l'union européenne alors que le
royaume uni s'apprêtent à quitter
l'union et que le prochain scrutin
risque d'installer au parlement européen
une majorité de députés hostiles aux
valeurs humanistes qui malgré le rejet
croissant de l'europe par les peuples
auraient pu nous mobiliser encore pour
la défendre
il nous est donc demandé de nous
prononcer sur la construit de
contribution à un budget pour lequel les
conséquences de la sortie du royaume uni
ne sont pas connues et dont nous ne
savons pas quelle utilisation politique
en fera la future majorité du parlement
européen à ces incertitudes majeures
s'ajoute le désaccord entre le conseil
et le parlement européen qui oblige la
commission a tenté trouver un compromis
entre deux propositions de budget dont
le montant divergent d'environ 2
milliards soit un peu plus d'un pour
cent de son montant global
je vous rappelle que ce dernier ne
représente qu'un petit peu plus de 1% du
pib communautaire
l'élaboration de ce dernier budget de la
mandature du parlement aurait pu être
l'occasion d'une discussion sur le fond
et d'une réflexion sur le projet
européen
une seule priorité fait consensus la
protection des frontières extérieures et
la gestion du phénomène migratoire pour
le reste
l'action la commission européenne semble
essentiellement concentrée sur le rejet
du budget
italien qui n'aura pour conséquence que
de renforcer le camp de ses opposants
ces petites querelles semble
indifférente aux crises majeures que
l'europe va affronter elles ne sont pas
dignes des espoirs placés dans la
construction européenne par les
générations sortie du chaos de la
dernière guerre elle m'évoque une oeuvre
du poète grec constantin cavafy dont je
vous lis deux extraits qu'attendons nous
rassembler sur l'agora
on dit que les barbares seront là
aujourd'hui
pourquoi cette léthargie au sénat
pourquoi les sénateurs reste-t-il sans
légiférer parce que les barbares seront
là aujourd'hui
à quoi bon faire des lois à présent ce
sont les barbares qui les feront bientôt
pourquoi ce trouble cette subite
inquiétudes comme les visages sont
graves
pourquoi places et rues si vite déserté
pourquoi chacun reparte il chez lui le
visage soucieux parce que la nuit est
tombée et que les barbares ne sont pas
venus et certains qui arrivent des
frontières disent qu'il n'y a plus de
barbares mais alors qu'allons nous
devenir sans les barbares ces gens
étaient en somme une solution comme sur
l'agora de constantin cavafy il semble
que l'évocation des barbares ceux de
l'intérieur pour certains et de
l'extérieur pour d'autres soit devenu
l'unique préoccupation d'élite incapable
de proposer aux citoyennes et aux
citoyens un projet transcendant qui
puisse à la fois nous éviter les
repliement nationaliste et la gestion
libérale et technocratique owni d'une
part toujours plus importante des
peuples européens
écoutez la jeunesse son désir d'europe
et ambitieux généreux et prometteur elle
s'est forgée progressivement dans la
tourmente des renoncements successifs
une conscience européenne nouvelle qui
demande pour les citoyens de cette union
futur plus de droits sociaux plus de
solidarité entre les territoires
une défense sans comprend
des libertés individuelles une
association est tendue et renouveler au
fonctionnement démocratique des
institutions européennes est au dessus
de tout une action d'envergure en faveur
de l'environnement et du climat car
l'union européenne est le seul espace
est la seule institution dans lequel et
par laquelle il serait possible d'agir
efficacement pour sauver notre humanité
en danger aucune de ses ambitions n'est
portée par le projet de budget européen
pourquoi accepter ainsi la catastrophe
annoncée qui est stimulant
chers collègues de pouvoir aborder les
questions européennes
même en six minutes même par le biais du
prélèvement au titre de la participation
de la france au budget de l'union
européenne
quand le délai le camp le débat européen
centrale pour notre vie politique est
maintenant relégué à de rares séances de
questions réponses techniques
oui chers collègues le sénat gagnerait à
se saisir de la politique européenne
qu'elle merci pour la confirmation de
cette convergence quelques observations
rapide
premièrement la contribution de la
france au budget de l'union européenne
s'établit à 21 8 515 milliards d'euros
pour 2019 et doit être approuvée que le
quinquennat précédent est loin quant à
la fin de chaque année
l'exécution partielle des engagements
budgétaires européens au frais une
recette importante sans fatigue
même chose pour les charges d'intérêt de
la dette ou la réduction des dotations
aux collectivités toutes ses économies
sans grand effort et sans mérite ont été
brûlés dans l'augmentation des dépenses
publiques avec une meilleure exécution
en fin de mandat de la commission
notre budget 2010 neuf doigts al'inverse
absorber une augmentation de la
contribution de plus de 8%
deuxième observation nous pouvons pas
tout demander à l'europe
sans lui en donner les moyens la
première pédagogie vis-à-vis de nos
concitoyens et d'expliquer que le budget
de l'union européenne sort en 2010 9 260
65,5 milliards d'euros quand celui de
notre pays sera de 3 190 8 milliards
d'euros et plus de 500 milliards pour
notre budget social très clairement
linverse de ce dont notre opinion
publique est probablement convaincu
troisièmement gardons nous de tout
doublé discours l'un à paris l'autre à
bruxelles pour le futur cadre
pluriannuel 2021 2027 à 1,11 % show doit
utiliser des mots du jargon européen du
revenu national brut
il ne sera pas possible d'absorber la
perte des 14 milliards d'euros de la
contribution britannique où des
politiques nouvelles de 20 à 30
milliards d'euros qui sont souhaitées
par l'europe en matière par exemple vous
le savez tous de migration de défense ou
de lutte contre le terrorisme
cela supposerait de monter la
participation des pays à 1,2 pour cent
mais la france and at elle les moyens
en appel la volonté et si oui au prix de
quelles économies parallèles
nous ne sommes pas très loin de du sujet
d'actualité qui paralyse au moins
partiellement notre pays et qui
préoccupe à juste titre chacune et
chacun d'entre eux d'entre eux cette
question de notre niveau de
participation et en particulier de la
capacité budgétaire de notre pays à y
faire face conditionne les questions des
fonds de cohésion et de la politique
agricole commune que vous venez cher de
collègues développons avec quelles
ressources propres
l'europe dépend de la contribution des
états encore plus autorisées mois le
parallèle que nos collectivités
dépendent des dotations de
étant l'autonomie fiscale revendiquée
par les collectivités locales françaises
est aussi un sujet pour l'union
européenne avec un arrière-plan des
ressources telles que la taxation sur
les plastiques
mais peut-être de manière plus
importante
la question des revenus très saoul
fiscalisés de l'économie numérique alors
que les solutions à nos problèmes
principaux sont largement européenne la
maîtrise des migrations par exemple ne
se joue pas à l'échelle d'un seul état
mais engage plusieurs modes d'action
convergent à l'échelle du continent
européen
les etats-unis la chine la russie vous
le savez tous entre autres ont engagé un
nouveau cycle historique et à ce titre
probablement durable dans lequel le
rapport de forces est devenu une forme
de normes sociales mondiale le défi
n'est donc pas lancé à la france pas
plus qu'à la belgique ou à la suède ou à
telle ou telle autre
pays européens il est lancé à tous les
européens qui ont constitué avec le
temps le premier marché mondial la
première économie et qui instruit par
des souffrances de l'histoire
connaissent l'importance d'une
régulation multilatérale ou les risques
dîner générés par des inégalités
économiques toujours plus grand c'est
dire mes chers collègues
en conclusion que le bon sens la raison
l'expérience vous prendrez la base que
vous souhaitez veulent que nous portions
une ambition européenne et pas
simplement une ambition discours pour
reprendre une formule que j'ai entendu
dans la discussion générale tout à
l'heure sur les lois de finances
et s'il vous restait un doute les
fractures britannique l'angoissent
devant le saut dans le ville devrait
nous en contre
merci de votre attention merci chers
collègues chez ouzoulias vous l'avez
évoqué un accord n'a pas pu être trouvé
sur le budget européen 2019
lors de la conciliation entre le
parlement européen et le conseil des
ministres qui s'est achevée lundi soir à
bruxelles la même situation s'était
produite il y a quatre ans pour le
budget 2015
durant ces discussions le conseil à
veiller à garantir le financement des
priorités politiques tout en assurant
une budgétisation prudente en crédit
dans le but de conserver la marge
nécessaire pour faire face aux imprévus
en cours d'année
la négociation a échoué en grande partie
en raison d'un point de principe sur la
technique budgétaire auquel le parlement
est attaché il s'agit de la possibilité
de recycler des crédits non consommés
dans le cadre des projets les programmes
de recherche
mais sur ce point le conseil s'y oppose
traditionnellement qui ne veut pas créer
de précédent ce blocage vous l'avait
bien dit ne paraît pas à la hauteur des
enjeux
conformément aux dispositions du traité
et comme elle l'avait fait en 2014 la
commission va proposer un projet de
budget révisé d'ici quelques jours afin
qu'un budget soit adopté d'ici la fin de
l'année
je rappelle que
ce désaccord devait persister l'union
passerait alors comme elle l'a fait à
trois reprises dans les années 80 au
système des douzièmes provisoires mais
ce n'est évidemment pas ce que nous
souhaitons le projet révisé de budget
européen pour 2019 que présentera la
commission d'ici la fin du mois
conservera sans doute les mêmes grandes
orientations en intégrant à la marge
certaines adaptations
c'est un budget qui permet de préparer
le prochain cadre financier pluriannuel
dont nous reparlerons en faisant un
effort sur des dépenses nouvelles
j'ajoute immédiatement que sur les 165,6
milliards d'euros en crédits
d'engagement et les 140 8,7 milliards de
crédits de paiement du projet de budget
initial les priorités classiques que
sont la pac et la politique de cohésion
reste bien évidemment les principales
masse du budget européen
nous y avons veiller attentivement je
souligne aussi que nous bénéficions plus
des budgets européens que par le passé
nous étions en volume en 2010 est le
premier bénéficiaire des dépenses de
l'union alors qu'en 2016 nous étions le
troisième et nous étions en 2010 est le
troisième contributeur net
après avoir été le deuxième en 2016 je
je soutiens ce que vous disiez monsieur
le sénateur mais non ville nous avons
beaucoup à retirer de ce budget européen
ce budget prévoit de faire monter en
puissance la croissance et l'innovation
ainsi que les mesures en faveur de la
jeunesse
je pense à la montée en charge d'erasmus
plus vous en avait parlé
monsieur le sénateur sutour pour
permettre à de plus en plus d'étudiants
mais aussi désormais d'apprentis de se
former en europe
dans le même temps il contribuera à une
meilleure politique migratoire et un
meilleur contrôle des frontières de
l'union
ainsi qu'à une plus forte solidarité
au-delà de ces
en continuant notamment à financer
l'accompagnement l'éducation et
d'hébergement des personnes qui fuient
les conflits en syrie et ailleurs
autres priorités nouvelles et
importantes les questions de défense
l'année 2019 marquera une avancée
majeure pour le volet industriel est
capacitaire de l'europe de la défense
composante incontournable de l'autonomie
stratégique européenne un programme
européen dédié permettra en effet aux
entreprises européennes d'unir leurs
forces pour financer des projets en
commun
il préfigure ainsi le futur fonds
européen de défense que la commission
européenne propose de doter de 13
milliards d'euros dans le prochain cadre
financier pluriannuel 2021 2027
cela amène tout naturellement à évoquer
avec vous les prochaines perspectives
financières pour l'après 2020
comme vous l'avez souligné notamment
monsieur le sénateur rapin la sortie du
royaume uni de l'union entraînera par la
même occasion le départ d'un importants
contributeurs nets au budget européen en
complexifiant d'autant une négociation
qui requiert déjà l'unanimité des états
membres
je doute que nous ayons un accord comme
le souhaiterait la commission avant les
élections européennes
ou encore que nous puissions dégager dès
décembre de premier niveau de
financement du prochain cadre financier
pluriannuel
ce serait d'ailleurs un étrange message
que de dire aux électeurs que les
priorités et les moyens budgétaires
correspondants sont définis avant qu'il
ne se soit exprimé
je les appelais le 12 novembre dernier
lors du conseil affaires générales le
conseil européen y reviendra au mois de
décembre
parmi les défis auxquels l'europe est
confrontée de nouvelles priorités sont
apparus ou non en puissance les
migrations les enjeux de des structures
it et de défense je les mentionnaient à
l'instant
ou bien encore la compétitivité de
l'économie européenne à travers
l'innovation et la recherche
tout comme l'avenir de notre jeunesse et
le changement climatique
vous avez raison monsieur le sénateur
ouzoulias ce pour autant nous ne
saurions en aucun cas sacrifier les
politiques traditionnels et tout
spécialement la politique agricole
commune qui n'a rien perdu de son
actualité
bien au contraire vous êtes nombreux à
l'avoir dit je le redis donc à nouveau
devant vous la pac ne peut pas être la
variable d'ajustement du breakbeat et
une baisse de ses moyens ne sera pas
acceptée nous sommes parvenus à
mobiliser largement et ce sont
aujourd'hui 21 s est à membres qui ont
demandé un maintien du budget de la pac
à son niveau actuel pour l'union
européenne à 27
par ailleurs le budget doit traduire la
solidarité de l'union et refléter ses
valeurs c'est pourquoi la france
soutient aux côtés de nombreux états
membres
la proposition de la commission de
renforcer le lien entre l'octroi de
financements européens et le respect des
valeurs fondamentales de l'union
nous estimons d'ailleurs qu'il convient
d'aller plus loin afin que le budget
européen puisse également favoriser la
convergence des états en matière fiscale
et sociale essentielle au bon
fonctionnement du marché intérieur
j'ajoute que nous souhaitons intégrer au
cadre financier pluriannuel à 27
un budget de la zone euro pour les 19
bruno le maire et son collègue allemand
olaf scholz ont présenté nos idées à cet
égard le 19 novembre le départ du
royaume uni représente une occasion
historique de remettre à plat le système
de financement du budget européen
la commission a fait des propositions
qui vont dans le bon sens mais il nous
faut aller jusqu'au bout de cette
logique
c'est pourquoi nous demandons la
suppression totale et immédiate des
rabais monsieur le sénateur a peint et
soutenons également la mise en place de
nouvelles ressources propres
comme vous l'avez indiqué madame la
sénatrice
mélo ou monsieur le sénateur
bonnecarrère notamment dans le domaine
environnemental mais aussi du numérique
monsieur le rapporteur jolie monsieur le
sénateur sutour la france a indiqué
qu'elle était prête à un budget à 27 en
expansion sous plusieurs conditions
une modernisation des politiques des
conditionnalités dans l'emploi des fonds
de nouvelles ressources propres et une
suppression complète des rabais un
dernier mot enfin sur votre question
monsieur le rapporteur jolie concernant
le financement des investissements
je voudrais notamment parlé du
financement des investissements
portuaires induits par le brr exit ce
budget est fondé sur une hypothèse celle
de l'obtention d'un accord de retrait
nous y sommes au niveau technique il est
vraisemblable qu'un sommet se tiendra
dimanche que les vingt-sept soutiendront
l'accord de retrait et la déclaration
politique sur la relation future but
ni et l'union européenne mais vous êtes
plusieurs à y avoir fait allusion
il reste une incertitude celle de la
ratification par le parlement
britannique
cette incertitude est forte
ce n'est pas la première s'agissant du
brésil mais nous devons être prêts à
tous les scénarios et donc quoi qu'il en
soit le gouvernement est
particulièrement conscient des enjeux qu
implique en particulier pour nos ports
la sortie du royaume uni notamment pour
faire face aux nouvelles formalités de
contrôle
c'est d'ailleurs vrai quelle que soit la
date à laquelle ces contrôles devraient
être mises en place dès le 30 mars en
cas d'absence d'accord de retrait à la
fin de la période de transition
si la nouvelle relation future justifie
ces contrôles le coordonnateur national
nommé par le premier ministre est en
train de finaliser l'estimation des
besoins avec l'ensemble des acteurs
concernés et j'étais pour ma part avec
le premier ministre la semaine dernière
à dunkerque pour évaluer directement
avec les acteurs du port de dunkerque
les investissements à faire les
recrutements à mener et l'organisation
de ces contrôles de nous avions perdu
l'habitude dans le trafic transmanche
pour ne parler que du volet européen qui
nous concerne aujourd'hui je vous
confirme que nous travaillons pour que
les programmes communautaires permettent
de financer des adaptations en briques
site dès maintenant puis le cas échéant
dans les premières années du prochain
cadre financier pluriannuel la
commission ouvrira par ailleurs en
décembre prochain un appel d'offres du
mécanisme d'interconnexion en europe
dotée de 65 millions d'euros pour
cofinancer des projets de liaisons
transfrontalières et pour la connexion
et le développement des ports maritimes
du réseau global
nous nous mobilisons pour que le plus
grand nombre possible de ports français
puissent participer aux futurs appels
d'offres du corridor mer du nord
méditerranée
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs l'union
européenne n'est parfait
bien au contraire et nous sommes
convaincus avec le président de la
république qu'elle doit changer en
profondeur
j'ai d'ailleurs recueilli à ce propos
les remarques et les propositions de nos
concitoyens vous y faisiez allusion
madame la sénatrice mélo lors des
consultations citoyennes sur l'europe
ce travail de refondation est engagé
l'union déterminera par le prochain
cadre financier pluriannuel ces grands
choix politiques pour la période à venir
d'ici là le budget européen pour 2019
donnera les moyens à l'union et à la
france d'être plus efficace plus forte
plus protectrice
c'est pourquoi au nom du gouvernement je
vous demande d'autoriser le prélèvement
sur recettes au profit de l'union
européenne pour l'année 2019
je vous remercie merci madame la
ministre
donc l'ensemble des groupes se sont
exprimés manama ministre aussi donc nous
allons passer au vote sur l'article 37
donc je mets aux voix l'article 37 qui
est pour certains articles 37 qui et
contre qui s'abstient il est adopté
et voilà le sénat a validé hier soir la
contribution de la france au budget de
l'union européenne il s'élève à 21,5
milliards d'euros et dans ce débat les
sénateurs ont déploré le retard des
aides européennes versées en retour à la
france et notamment les aides de la
politique agricole commune ainsi que les
crédits pour les territoires ruraux la
part de la france dans ce budget
européen est en hausse cette année d'un
v6 milliards d'euros et elle devrait
continuer d'augmenter avec le break site
et le retrait du royaume uni de l'union
européenne rappelle qu'un accord a été
trouvé sur le break site et ouvre une
période de transition de deux ans pour
sceller le divorce avec les britanniques
mais pendant cette période de deux ans
le royaume-uni devra se comporter comme
un membre de l'union européenne comme
les autres et donc payer sa part du
budget c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de nous avoir suivis vous pouvez
voir toutes nos émissions sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr vous souhaite
une très bonne journée et un très bon
week-end sur les chaînes parlementaires
m
[Musique]